bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre sur
TVfil 78 nouvelle édition du 78 et les
18h si vous nous rejoignez en direct je
reçois tout d'abord Xavier Maurice
bonsoironsir vous êtes candidat à la
Chambre d'Agriculture d'Île-de-France
pour la Confédération paysane dans
quelques minutes le point sur ce scrutin
qui se déroule à la fin du mois de
janvier sur votre programme également le
monde agricole qui en Île-de-France plus
particulièrement s'inquiète de la
réduction des terres cultivables
également invité tout à l'heure Frédéric
gras il est photographe il partip
participe à une opération solidaire des
clichés contre des dons pour le Secours
populaire et puis au cours de la
chronique de l'environnement des
formateurs du lycée agricole de Mle
bonsoir Valérie bonsoir Il viendront
nous parler notamment d'une formation
peu connue oui et surtout unique
formation sanctionnée par un diplôme
d'état dans toute l'île de France nous
recevrons pour cela deux enseignants qui
viendront nous parler de cette filière
animalerie unique la chronique de
l'environnement dans une vingtaine de
minutes le reste de l'actualité en image
à présent les principaux titres qui
seront développés au travers de nos
reportages Mani les Hot au cœur de
toutes les attentions politiques pour
ses premiers vœux le nouveau maire
Bertrand Ouillon a été soutenu par un
ministre socialiste Benoît amont par la
présidente du PS également départemental
Sandrine grambe le travail le dimanche
le dossier est juridique il est aussi
social et humain nous nous sommes rendus
dans une enseigne de bricolage dimanche
dernier pour voir ce qu'en pensaient
client et salariés et ils sont unanimes
le travail le dimanche quand il est
volontaire c'est un plus pour que les
satellites envoient les bonnes
informations il dispose de réflecteurs
des réflecteurs fabriqués à la main par
asrium au Mureau du mdine Eveline de
très haute technologie et enfin portrait
de Dalila couturière d'intérieur et
tapissière elle s'est occupée des
rideaux et des tapisseries du Châ de
Breteuil à Choisel le travail de le
dimanche il fait beaucoup parler
notamment les responsables politiques
pour autant qu'en pense les salariés et
qu'en pense également à les clients
Alice Gastine et lodim moine ont-elles
aussi travaillé un dimanche pour
réaliser ce reportage auprès d'une
grande enseigne de bricolage regardez
les salariés des principales enseignes
de bricolage mobilisés sur les réseaux
sociaux objectif conserver le droit au
travail dominical et sur le terrain
aussi il ne manque pas l'occasion de
faire passer leur message comme ici à
Bois d'Arcy c'est complètement basé sur
le volontariat on signe tous les ans des
feuilles où on met le nombre de
dimanchees qu'on souhaite faire ou pas
si on n'est pas volontaire on le met
aussi pour dire qu'on ne souhaite pas
travailler le dimanche à moi ça me gêne
absolument pas de travailler le dimanche
étant donné que je suis en cours toute
la semaine du lundi au vendredi pour moi
travailler le weekend ça me permet de
pas du tout empiéter sur ma semaine de
cours donc tous les jours donc c'est
vraiment parfait et en plus de ça on est
rémunéré en conséquence donc pour moi
c'est un béfice et c'est nécessaire pour
moi ça représente aucun problème le seul
problème c'est qu'on soit obligé de se
battre pour pouvoir travailler le
dimanche les salariés sont quasi unanime
quant au fait de travailler le dimanche
les clients aussi sont enthousiastes
même s'il ne semble pas favorable à une
généralisation de l'ouverture dominicale
à l'ensemble des commerces je suis
plutôt contre l'ouverture des magasins
le dimanche mais tant qu'ils sont
ouverts j'y vais mais je comprendrait
très bien que les gens ne veuillent plus
travailler le dimanche c'est tout à fait
normal aprè c'est un peu plus au cas par
cas enfin c'est vrai que le bricolage on
fait souvent ça le weekend après les
courses enfin pour l'alimentaire par
exemple j'ai moins d'avis làdessus parce
que on fait ça la semaine tant que
l'employé s'y retrouve c'est bien si
l'employé s'y retrouve pas ça sert à
rien la loi encadre de manière stricte
l'ouverture le dimanche les magasins
doivent être situés dans une zone
touristique ou sur un pus un périmètre
d'usage de consommation exceptionnel
certains braves les interdit comme
Bricorama qui a été assigné en justice
et interdit d'ouvrir le
dimanche c'est c'est un gros manque à
gagné pour moi personnellement ça
représente 10 % de mon chiffre d'affair
à l'année le dimanche h et dans la
communauté des nous avons des magasins
où cela représente à peu près 25 % de
leur chiff d'affaires les EMB étaient
gelés ça cétait sûr et après il a fallu
revoir après le la restructuration du
magasin afin de de combler cette perte
suite à ce verdict bricoorama a signé en
justice deux de ses concurents le roi
Merlin et Castorama qui sont ouverts le
dimanche
du 21 au 31 janvier 10 jours pour élir
leurs représentants pour les
agriculteurs pour un mandat de 6 ans les
Chambres d'agriculture fondé en 1924 ce
sont des organismes chargés de
représenter l'ensemble des différents
agents économiques de l'agriculture et
on va en parler avec notre invité Xavier
Maurice tout d'abord on vient de voir un
reportage sur le travail le dimanche
j'imagine que chez vous dans vos
exploitations le travail le dimanche
c'est une règle euh oui vous êtes bien
loin de ce débat sur le travail le
dimanche ou non oui mais enfin bon
disons bon personnellement je pense aux
salariés au autes qui doivent travailler
le dimanche et je me mets à leur place
je suis assez partagé sur le travail
dimanche bien que sur les exploations
effectivement vous soyez amené à
travailler 7 jours sur 7 et 24 sur 24
voilà alors on va revenir à ces
élections en Île-de-France 2811
électeurs du collège des exploitants
dont 1115 pour le département des ivelin
c'est le département le plus important
en terme d'électeur vous êtes candidat
pour la Confédération paysane vousmême
agricul en quoi cette élection est si
importante si importante pardon bon une
ch d'agriculture c'est c'est là que que
que que se prennent les décision de
l'orientation agricole du département
bon participer à à ces élections bon
c'est c'est des des scrutins de liste et
bon on va participer par la suite à
l'orientation de
l'agriculture éventuellement à à rentrer
dans les commissions départementales
d'orientation agricole pour arriver à à
à dispatcher un petit peu le foncier
agricole ça permet aussi également
laisser de autre l'installation des
jeunes qui qui nous manque un petit peu
quand même sur l'île de France et dans
d'autres régions et et voilà bon c'est
mais est-ce que les chambres agricoles
véritablement pèsent se font entendre
est-ce que ça a un poids véritablement
est-ce que les agriculteurs en sont
conscients également est-ce qu'ils sont
mobilisés en général pour ces élections
les agriculteurs peut-être moins ou
autres mais les les Chambres
d'agriculture pèsent
dans même même en île-de-fance on a une
chambre d'agriculture qui qui est bien
représenté et autres et et qui pèse
quand même disons bon que ce soit même
au niveau
région bon
a elle un pouvoir quand même
décisionnaire d'information également
des élus autres et et bon je pense qu'
elle a un grand rôle à jouer que
représente le monde agricole en Île de
France parce qu'on pense souvent à
urbanisation sur ces territoires là ne
serait-ce que sur le département des
ivelines aussi mais ça occupe encore une
grande place ces différentes
exploitations euh oui il y a il y a
encore quand même sur l'île-de-fance
ouest disons et il y a il y a plus de
3000 3000 inscrits donc c'est 3000
exploitants h euh bon il y a il y a des
des couples qui votent également mais
disons bon ça ça il y a pour nous il y a
il y a encore bon nombre d'exploitations
bon le problème
euh les exploitations disparaissent ou
autres bon souvent c'est
l'accandissement des exploitations H qui
partent bon pour des terres calières et
bon c'est c'est peut-être un petit peu
bon la Confédération paysane ce qu'on
souhaite c'est un petit peu enrayer
l'agrandissement des exploitations pour
ça qu'on présente on va parler justement
de ces différents points de programme
juste un mot auparavant sur le poids que
représente actuellement la Confédération
paysane dans cette chambre d'agriculture
île-de-fance on a un élu depuis 6 ans on
a un élu sur sur 63 bon dans le collège
des exploitant agricool il y a que 23
exploitants et on a toujours un
élu et comment vous expliquez ces
résultats obtenu sur le
der la Confédération paysane c'est c'est
un c'est un syndicat qui est jeune par
l'âge ou
autre bon il y a on a à peine 20 ans
d'existence bon sur l'île-de- France bon
on a on a constitué le syndicat dans les
années 2000 donc bon faut arriver à un
transfert à changer les mentalités euh
et de scrutin en scrutin nous nous on
perçoit quand même qu'il y a un
changement des mentalités en état
d'esprit et de l'état d'esprit des des
exploitants vous êtes candidat pour la
Confédération paysane numéro 2 sur cette
liste dans votre programme on trouve
donc la volonté de développer une
politique d'installation en phase avec
la réalité sociale c'est-à-dire quelle
est la réalité sociale aujourd'hui bon
moi je trouve moi je suis je suis un peu
attristé de voir des exploitations
maréchaires euh arboricol ou autre qui
qui qui qui disparaissent sur
généralement sur toutes lesî de France
dans d'autres dans toute autre région
également et disons bon la réalité
sociale bon bah c'est des exploitations
spécialisées autes qui qui procurent de
l'emploi et bon ça va avec les les
fondements de de la Confédération
paysane B on est assez partisan de de
l'aspect social de l'agriculture il y a
aussi une volonté de développer les
circuits court également ça c'est
important alors c'estàd les circuit
court même chose circuit court bon c'est
les marchés c'est c'est des des ventes
en AMAP et on on est c'est un petit peu
la pas la base mais disons bon tous les
exploitants en majorité les exploitants
de la qui qui sont la Confédération
paysane vendent en circuit court sur
notre liste de 23 candidats 80 % des
candidats sont en circuit court sont en
relation directe avec le consommateur
c'est quelque chose qui se développe le
consommateur est est demandeur aussi de
ces circuits court d'être en contact
direct avec les
oui surtout surtout en en Île-de-France
bon on a on a des des agglomérations à
proximité de moins en moins de de
producteurs moi c'est c'est c'est un
petit peu ce qui me ce qui me désole
quoi dis on arrive à un vieillissement
de la population également mais
justement qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait pour
renouveler ces agriculteurs on va dire
renouveler les générations faire arriver
de nouvelles générations ok des facil
disons le le problème c'est c'est c'est
l'accès au fonciers même des des
néoruraux des des des des jeunes
extérieurs à l'agriculture ou autre ont
du mal à pouvoir accéder au foncier que
ça soit par achat ou par le par par le
fermage trouver des terrains locations
ut et c'est ces décisions là ils se
prennent bon en chambreculture qui donne
une orientation mais j'insiste ça ça se
décide dans les comités départementaux
d'orientation agricole c'est là on on
statue sur sur l'installation de desjà
et et et c'est là qui est la décision
quel est votre parcours vous vous êtes
installé quand vous justement euh nous
on se s'est installé en
81 j'ai créé l'exploitation de toute
pièces pe rappeler où se situe cette
exploitation je suis à saint-an la
bretche disons bon on parle d'exode
rural ou de désertification des
campagnes ou de disparition
d'explitation nous il y a 30 ans on a eu
la chance parce que c'est une chance de
pouvoir créer notre exploitation
mais on l'a créé toute pièces bon on l'
eu 25 ans de de galère on va dire
mais on a on est parvenu à installer
notre fils avec nous et on installe un
jeun c'est un petit peu notre petite
fierté si on veut avoir créé une
exploitation et installer des jeunes et
je pense bon ben pour ma part je tiens à
urer dans le même sens et promouvoir
l'installation de jeunes dans la région
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure la la
réduction justement des des
exploitations en introduction de cette
émission est-ce que vous y êtes
confronté justement à ce problème de
voir les exploitations réduites au
profit justement de de toute
l'urbanisation euh bah pour notre part
là on va on va perdre 11 hectares euh
donc on a une exploitation de 100
hectares
euh pour des réalisations pour des réis
pour des réalisations oui bon voà ça va
être une construction de pavillon
pavillonnaire et une ZAC
euh on a et on a aucun pouvoir vraiment
disons bon
on est un peu obligé d'accepter mais ces
décisions là iles sont prises à la
région au
département par des responsab les
responsables politiques munici
l'importance aussi d'avoir une chambre
d'agriculture qui soit suffisamment
importante représentative pour que
chacun se se fasse entendre notamment
dans le monde agricole un mot juste pour
terminer par rapport au programme de la
Confédération paysane sur les
agrocarburants ça aussi c'était plutôt
tendance et la Confédération paysane est
plutôt contre oui nous à la
Confédération paysane bon on on est on
est contre disons bon et et finalement
bon une cérale du blé haute qui va finir
en éthanol bon une cérale c'est pour
faire du pain ou pour nourrir des
animaux c'est pas pour finir dans le
réservoir les véhicules quoi bon sur la
partie diester colza ou autrees bon on
est peut-être un peu plus nuancé mais
mais disons en tout cas pas sur les
céréales VO non pas sur les céréales
transant sur les céréales pour pour moi
du blé c'est fait pour faire du pain
merci x d'être venu sur ce plateau on
rappelle les dates de ces Chambre
d'Agriculture 21 31 janvier par
correspondance vous êtes candidat pour
la Confédération paysane numéro 2 sur la
liste en Île-de France merci à vous les
cérémonies de vœux des MRES se déroulent
tout au long du mois de janvier comment
s dérouler celle de manilé am c'était
lundi soir de nombreux responsables
politiques étaient présent nous allons
en parler dans un instant pour l'instant
que vous souhaitez pour 2013 tout au
long du mois de janvier nous allons à
votre rencontre micro trottoir signé dè
le diine ce soir j'aimerais que mes
enfants conservent le et puis que mes
petits enfants puissent réussir dans
leur travail scolaire et qu'ils soient
heureux avec leurs parents voilà tout le
monde soit heureux d'avoir beaucoup
d'argent et la santé surtout et écoutez
tous mes vœux de bonheur et de bonne
santé à tous les ivelinois donc profitez
bien de cette année
2013 surtout bon courage vu les temps
difficiles